Mr. Trump's language is divisive.
I want to win.
I want one of these people here or the ones at 5 o'clock,...
...to be the next president of the United States.
I've had my issues with Donald Trump.
You've called women you don't like "fat pigs," "dogs," "slobs,"...
...and "disgusting animals."
Your Twitter account...
Only Rosie O'Donnell.
No, it wasn't.
Lenders to your companies lost billions of dollars.
Question sir, with that record, why should we trust you to run the nation's business?
I have never gone bankrupt, by the way.
I have never.
We need to build a wall and it has to be built quickly.
And I don't mind having a big beautiful door in that wall...
...so that people can come into this country legally.